I'm sorry is closed today you better
pack it up and get out of here speak for
myself in this city and on this planet
[Music]
where's your gun
I don't know everybody having a thing
it's no time for a thing that's the
thing right there let's go
[Music]
dude your bears to me from the Wizards I
I can't stand down thank you are you
yawning in the middle of this while I'm
breaking it down huh did you hear what I
said stop listening after you said you
we need a plan
okay mr. clean is on his own page I see
not winging it isn't really what they do
um what exactly is it that they do kick
names take out
all right just get over here please mr.
lorn can you get your folks to circle up
mr. Lord star-lord is fine we've got a
cold ice because if all we come at him
with us a plucky attitude dude don't
call us plucky we don't know what means
all right we're optimistic yes I like
your plan except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
good
oh don't know the closest Vista
[Music]
I'm gonna ask one time who are you
you're the Avengers yeah
thanos
if he gets all the Infinity stones
he'll wipe out half the universe
everything you know everything you love
it will all be gone just like that well
he's never Ford me yeah he has he's
never fought me twice I'm getting new
hammer hammer he's coming to us I say we
take the fight to him
[Music]
you guys are screwed
[Applause]
[Music]
oh by the way this is a friend of mine
tree hi I'm Steve Rogers together we can
stop
[Music]
dude you're embarrassing me in front of
the wizard so we got all kinds of
details about the infinity war blu-ray
the deleted scenes the bonus features
and we found out what's going on with
black panther 2 so let's break it down
if you're finding me for the first time
there is a new round of the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber leave a
comment on the video there's new details
about how to contact me for a giveaway
stuff at the end of the video - because
YouTube changed a couple features so
I've already done a couple videos about
some of the deleted scenes that the
Russos talked about putting on the
blu-ray now we have a complete list with
official descriptions for each of them
so the first one is called strange
alchemy share the thrill of characters
from across the MCU meeting for the
first time and discover why some were
teamed up together
that's them doing a bonus feature for
why they made the team's what they are
like why Iron Man spider-man and the
guardians are teaming up why Thor teamed
up with rocket and Groot for a little
while white cap Secret Avengers went to
Wakanda first a lot of that is pretty
self-explanatory like Bucky was in
Wakanda
cappen already been working with Black
Panther it would make sense that he
would go to the most secure location on
earth
the next featurette is just called the
mad Titan is just all about Thanos
obviously explored the MCS biggest
baddest villain his trail of influence
through the stories and the existential
threat he represents there are two big
featurettes for the two big battles
during the movie the one on Titan in the
one in Wakanda they just call it beyond
the battle is basically then doing the
behind the scenes for those huge battles
we got detailed descriptions of all the
deleted scenes - so this is actually
pretty cool first big one is happy knows
best as you says Tony and Pepper spar
over the details of their upcoming
wedding until a hassled happy Hogan
pulls up with an urgent request so
important detail there they're
definitely planning on getting married
there were a lot of people that were
wondering about the context of their
conversation because they were talking
about having children
the real reason why they had that Tony
Pepper scene was to set up stakes for
the Ironman character like these are the
things that he's fighting for a life
with pepper outside of the Avengers
anytime you see one of the main
characters talking with his love
interest who isn't involved in the movie
like pepper didn't really have much to
do with the plot of the film it's just
to set up stakes next big one is just an
extended scene from The Secret Avengers
Black Order fight
on a darkened Street Wanda Maximoff in
the wounded vision attempt to hide from
Thanos brutal allies so I'm guessing
that that battle was way longer and they
just cut it down for time next big one
the Guardians get their groove back
Peter quill and Drax quarrel over the
failed mission to nowhere mantis
interrupts with news they're talking
about this moment right here like right
after Theo stakes Kimura and they find
out that he's already got the reality
stone so this scene happens after this
moment here after Thanos ports away but
before they show up on Titan and start
fighting Iron Man spider-man and Doctor
Strange I know everybody still wants to
find out why is Gamora next big one
father's choice
Thanos confronts Gamora with a vision
from her past and with lying to him
about the soul stone this seems like an
extended version of the conversation
inside sanctuary - after they're on
their way - for mere or while they're on
the planet for mere walking up the
mountain and he's thinking about what he
has to do to get the soul stone gag real
only seems like it's about two minutes
long I know that doesn't seem like it's
very long that's about how long the
civil war blooper reel was and
thankfully they confirmed that there
will be a commentary on the movie from
the directors and the writers remember
this is the exact same team the same two
writers in the same two directors that
did Avengers 4 so it'll be interesting
to see if they drop any clues for what's
going on at the beginning of Avengers 4
so another important reason to listen to
blu-ray commentaries but just a reminder
digital is coming out July 30th the
blu-ray is coming out just a couple
weeks after that so no worries I'll do
videos for all these bonus features when
they actually drop right after Comic Con
it'll be the week after Comic Con pretty
much the other really big news
announcement Marvel had this morning was
about black panther 2 so I just posted a
video about the face for phase 5 movies
the Kevin Feige had confirmed and I
speculated that because they hadn't
locked Ryan Coogler down we were gonna
see black panther for a little while
longer than normal now what Marvel has
done is as they've moved
a mystery untitled mummy reboot so it'll
be a three year wait for black panther
in
instead of a two-year wait just because
it took him a little longer to get out
so it sounds like they're either almost
done negotiating his contract for black
panther 2 or they finished it in they're
getting ready to announce it later this
year
if they don't want it to get buried in
all the extra news announcements that
they have we learned a whole bunch of
stuff about the Game of Thrones prequels
so I'll do a video about that later
today obviously there's a whole bunch of
other news so leave all your requests in
the comments below but congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner Rob little
please message me on the back end of my
channel for those of you that didn't see
my announcement in my last big Marvel
video YouTube got rid of the messaging
tool now there is an email there where
you can actually contact me so that's
how we'll handle giveaway stuff it's
very prominently featured on the about
page of my youtube channel click here to
learn about all the phase 4 and phase 5
movies the Kevin Feige announced and
click here to learn about the big dragon
ball super announcement from yesterday
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]